after a few years in hibernation the box
office is set to Roar back to life in
2023 from Summer Blockbusters to Spooky
fall treats these are the major sequels
that you're going to want to see
2018 searching offered audiences a tight
tense Thriller about a desperate father
frantically trying to locate his missing
daughter told entirely through screens
using bones computer monitors and
televisions searching managed to weave
the everyday technology used by its main
characters into its Central narrative
turning what could have been an eye
rolling gimmick into a compelling
storytelling device however the mystery
told in searching felt pretty
definitively concluded by the end of the
film which makes the idea of a sequel
somewhat surprising and yet that's what
we're getting with deadline reporting in
August of 2019 that searching two now
titled missing is in the works it will
Mark the directorial debut of will
Merrick and Nick Johnson who edited the
original film and will also be Penning
part 2. but before you worry that making
a sequel to the Innovative Thriller
pushes the boundaries of plausibility
rest assured that this follow-up won't
be hurling Jon chose David Kim into an
improbable scenario instead missing will
focus on June a character played by
storm Reed who will have to use her
online Savvy after her mom and her mom's
boyfriend go missing in South America
prepare for high stakes and plenty of
cyber sleuthing when the film hits
theaters on January 20th 2023.
back in 2012 probably no one predicted
that the stripper film Magic Mike would
go on to spawn a successful trilogy but
the story is set to continue in Magic
Mike's Last Dance original movie Helmer
Steven Soderbergh is returning to the
director's chair and Channing Tatum will
reprise his semi-autobiographical role
as Mike Lane the plot finds Mike working
as a bartender in Miami where he meets a
lonely socialite played by Salma Hayek
impressed by his dancing abilities
Hayek's character decides to take Mike
to London and help him put on his own
theatrical show
let's go of course the stress of
treading the boards and navigating the
new Love Affair will definitely cause
some difficulties for our flexible
protagonist soderberger has majorly
emphasized the romance in this one which
will supposedly show Mike in a serious
relationship for the first time
Soderberg said during a Roundtable
interview in early 2022 the third movie
is the sort of apex of everything that
we've been talking about in that area
not just taking the dancing to another
level but really getting into the
relationship aspect that's been an
undercurrent in all of the films like
Mike has a full-on relationship that's
at the center of this movie while all
this stuff is going on and we haven't
done that before
Creed 2 ended with Michael B Jordan's
Adonis Creed a Victor in the boxing ring
and a father of a baby girl with his
fiancee Bianca so where will Creed 3
take us more importantly who's going to
take us there in addition to starring in
the film Jordan will make his
directorial debut with Creed 3. the
story is said to revolve around a
contentious friendship turned rivalry in
Creed 3 Adonis Creed will have to fight
Damien Dame Anderson a boxer just
getting out of prison after 18 years and
a childhood friend of creed was
something to prove and a lot of
resentment for his old associate playing
Damien Dame Anderson will be Lovecraft
country actor Jonathan Majors fresh from
his role as king the Conqueror and
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania on his
Creed 3 role Majors told nme with
intimacy comes complexity it's he and I
it's a story about these two men trying
to work something out they'll go
toe-to-toe on March 3rd 2023
before the bodies of the latest victims
of the Ghostface Killer even had a
chance to cool off a sequel to 2022's
newest scream installments had already
been greenlit by Paramount the fifth
installment in the scream franchise once
again saw Sydney Prescott's Gail
weathers and Dewey Riley on the run from
a killer in a ghost face mask along with
a host of new characters many of whom
were faded for a bloody ant the sixth
screen film will once again be held by
the filmmaking Trio radio Silence with
Matt bettinelli Oakland and Tyler
Gillette directing and the third member
Chad valella executive producing the
plots of scream films are always kept
heavily Under Wraps but it looks like
Ghostface is leaving Woodsboro to
terrorize the Big Apple Scream 6 taking
place in New York City sadly it looks
like a key player and the scream
franchise won't be showing up this time
Nev Campbell as Sydney Prescott as
reported by deadline Campbell wasn't
happy with the offer she got from the
studio to have her reprise her classic
role prepare to enjoy this super scary
movie on March 10 2023 a dazzlingly
original film full of humor action comic
book theatric tricks at heart 2018
Spider-Man into the spider-verse earned
375 million dollars at the global box
office Tacoma Academy Award for best
animated feature and became one of the
most critically acclaimed superhero
movies ever made naturally a follow-up
was officially announced in November
2019 with Christopher Miller and Phil
Lord returning as producers along with
new director joaquim desantos and
screenwriter David Callahan in April
2021 variety revealed that Kemp powers
and Justin Kate Thompson would join dos
Santos as co-directors according to a
deadline report from November 2022 miles
this universe is Spider-Man will team up
with a group of other spider-based
Heroes to wage battle against a
super-powered villain according to Sony
Pictures animations Twitter accounts the
villain is known as the spot an
interdimensional Baddie able to Sprint
through the Multiverse at incredible
speeds Spider-Man across the
spider-verse was initially set to hit
theaters in April 2022 but Sony pushed
the release to June 2nd 2023 and also
split the film in two the third film in
the series Spider-Man Beyond this
spider-verse will arrive on March 29
2024
directed by Stephen cable Jr
Transformers rise of the Beast will
bring back the popular Autobots while
introducing several Beast Wars
characters like Maximo leader Optimus
primal who will be voiced by Ron Perlman
with a cast that includes Anthony Ramos
Michelle yo Peter Dinklage and Pete
Davidson the movie will take place in
the 1990s as the autobots and maximoles
do battle with the Decepticons Predacons
and Terror cons
and down I'm not the one to fear Pride
the main villain of Rise of the Beast
will be the Terracon Scourge and the
film will also introduce his sidekick
night bird although voice actors have
not yet been confirmed for either
character Transformers rise of the Beast
is set to hit theaters June 9 2023. Capo
will be working from a scripture written
by Joby Harold who was also responsible
for the screenplay for King Arthur
legend of the sword he also wrote for
Disney Plus's Obi-Wan Kenobi series the
director is best known for directing
Creed 2 starring Michael B Jordan rise
of the Beast is expected to kick-start a
new Transformer series of at least three
movies promising plenty of Autobot
action for many years to come
as part of Disney's Whirlwind of
announcements during their 2020 investor
Day event the studio reaffirmed that a
fifth installment in the iconic Indiana
Jones franchise is on the way and will
once again star Indy himself Harrison
Ford at 80 years old Ford will likely be
retiring his trademark Whip and Fedora
by the end of Indiana Jones in the dial
of Destiny however we do know he'll be
joined in his Adventure by Phoebe Waller
Bridge of fleabag Fame who will be
playing Indy's goddaughter Helena Mass
Mickelson of Hannibal will play the
villain of the piece a Nazi scientist
working for the U.S government during
the space race and he'll be joined by a
packed cast including John rice Davies
reprising the role of Indy's trusted
companion Salah they'll all be
accompanied by a score from John
Williams who's returning for Indy's
newest Adventure in the director's chair
for Indiana Jones 5 is James Mangold who
previously directed 2017's Logan which
served as a seeming final adventure for
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine and Patrick
Stewart's Charles Xavier while Indiana
Jones 5 isn't likely to skew as dark as
Logan we can only hope that it's just
this movie farewell we'll see if they
stick The Landing when the film hits
theaters on June 30th 2023
the long-running Insidious franchise is
getting a fifth installment and this
time franchise star Patrick Wilson will
be settling into the director's chair
the first two films follow a couple
whose young son is haunted by
otherworldly beings and what happens
when the family fights back while the
third and fourth are prequels that focus
on the psychic who aided the heroes of
the first two films Insidious 5 will
follow the Sun from the original movie
now a decade older as he heads off to
college regarding his directorial duties
Wilson said in a statement I'm honored
and thrilled to be at the Helm of the
next Insidious installment which will
provide an amazing chance to unpack
everything the Lamberts went through a
decade ago as well as deal with the
consequences of their choices directing
the movie is both professionally and
personally a full circle moment for me
and I'm extremely grateful to be
entrusted and continuing to tell this
frightening and haunting story until the
further we go the script for insidious 5
was penned by Scott teams and based on a
story by Lee wanell who wrote the first
four Insidious films the fifth one will
creep into theaters on July 7 2023
when the Megs swam into theaters many
dismissed it as ridiculous think Jaws
but a lot Dumber but this Megalodon
movie earns some serious coin at the box
office drawing 528 million dollars
worldwide against a 130 million dollar
budget after all this is a movie where
Jason Statham goes to war with a
gigantic shark who doesn't want to see
that I'm gonna make this thing bleed
after audiences went into a beating
frenzy for the film plans were almost
immediately set in motion for a sequel
in October 2020 Warner Brothers
confirmed that Rebecca and high-rise
filmmaker Ben Wheatley will be humming
the sharktastic sequel we don't really
know what the plot will be but since the
Meg is actually based on a series of
books by Steve Alton the sequel might
draw on the next novel which involves an
even bigger shark as well as the giant
crocodile-like chronosaurus Meg 2 the
trench will be swimming into theaters on
August 4th 2023. after his
oscar-nominated performance as Macbeth
and the tragedy of big bath Denzel
Washington began prepping to Pivot into
a very different role by returning to
The Equalizer franchise in which he
plays ex-marine Robert McCall who tends
to go on violent vigilante tears when
people he cares about are harmed Helena
the girl you beat half to death Our
Lives couldn't go on the first equalizer
film saw Washington's character
protecting a teenage sex worker from the
Russian mafia while the second caught up
with him as he Avenged the death of one
of his friends from the first film
equalizer 3 will once again be directed
by Antoine Fuqua who held the first two
films although no official plot details
are known yet Hua mentioned in 2018 that
he had big plans to take Robert McCall
to Europe in his next adventure bukua
told slash film in June 2022 I think
that's the key to learn more about
Robert McCall we're shooting it in Italy
so that'd be fun as for Washington he's
looking forward to returning to the role
of McCall telling collider I gotta get
in shape and start beating people up
again I get to beat people up again the
tragedy of Macbeth and then going and
being eating some people up can't get
any better right the movie will also see
Washington reunite with Dakota Fanning
the two famously started together in
Tony Scott's 2004 Thriller Man on Fire
that like is back the Demonic nun who's
been haunting The Conjuring Universe
ever since the second film in the
franchise is getting her very own sequel
the non-terrorized audiences back in
2018 scaring up a whopping 365 million
dollars across the globe and whether
you're a Hollywood producer or a
malignant evil entity Money Talks
speaking of malignant Akila Cooper the
screenwriter behind James Wan's
absolutely Bonkers 2021 Thriller is
going to pen the script for the nun too
and she can bring the same wild energy
to Alex tail that she brought to
Gabriel's and this next installment in
The Conjuring franchise will be
something special indeed you've been a
bad bad boy Gabriel
[Applause]
there's no word yet on the plot but
we're waiting with baited terrified
breath The Conjuring the devil made me
do it director Michael shabs will Helm
the sequel which will take place in
1950s France and see Sister Irene face
off with valik Bonnie Ahrens is set to
reprise her role as the Demonic villain
taisa Farmiga will be back as Sister
Irene and storm Reed has been cast an
elite role on October 2022 deadline
noted the additions of Anna poppowell
and Caitlyn Rose Downey Papa well will
play a parochial school teacher and
Downey will portray her daughter prepare
to be scared on September 8 2023
and our current age of sequels remakes
and reboots of what can sometimes feel
like every significant film ever made
revisiting one of the most iconic horror
films of all time was all but inevitable
and sure enough The Exorcist 2 and 3 and
4 are in the works from Fright Factory
blumhouse Productions David Gordon green
who most recently wrote and directed the
new Halloween Trilogy for the studio
will Helm the new Trilogy which will be
penned by Green Danny McBride Scott
teams and Peter Sattler the original
Exorcist centered on a 12 year old girl
played by Linda Blair who was possessed
by a terrifying demon her mother hires
two priests played by Jason Miller and
Max von Sito to perform an exorcism
although spoiler alert both priests died
in the original film Ellen bursten will
reprise her role aiding new protagonist
Leslie Odom Jr as he searches for help
with his own possessed child the first
film in the new The Exorcist Trilogy
will get a theatrical release on October
13 2023 although there is a possibility
that the following two films could
premiere on the peacock streaming
platform
the power of Christ compels you if your
kids loved Paw Patrol the movie or if
you loved it they won't judge brace
yourself for maximum excitement because
it's getting the sequel in early
November 2021 Nickelodeon and Spin
Master entertainment greenlit Paw Patrol
the mighty movie which is set to receive
an exclusive theatrical release as for
the plot deadline reports that the
mighty movie will see a meteor land in
Adventure City a meteor that grants
superpowers to our adorable canine
Heroes unfortunately a mad scientist
teams up with their old rival mayor
Humdinger in a plot to steal their
powers for dastardly purposes in the
previous film the cast was played by a
list of All-Stars including Tyler Perry
Kim Kardashian and Randall Park while
none of those actors have confirmed
their involvement in the sequel it looks
like there's going to be just as much
talent on board this time around as
Taraji P Henson has signed on to voice
an unknown character the mighty movie
hits theaters October 13 2023.
want to play a game well jigsaw
certainly does the notorious serial
killer slash world's messiest self-help
Guru is coming back in August 2022 it
was announced that saw 10 will ride its
creepy little tricycle into theaters on
October 27 2023 just in time for
Halloween and Tobin Bell himself the
actor who's appeared as a jigsaw killer
in every installment except for 2021
spiral will slash his way back onto the
screen you won't be the only saw Alum
returning as the film will also star
Shawnee Smith who previously played John
Kramer's acolyte Amanda young the film
will be directed by Kevin grudert who
previously held saw six and saw the
Final Chapter
within days of the simultaneous
theatrical and HBO Max release of Dune a
sequel was officially greenlit with the
release date set for November 3rd 2023.
Dune part 2 won't come as a shock to
anyone who read Frank Herbert's novel or
saw the first film which ended at what
seemed to be a pretty pivotal point in
the character Arc of protagonist Paul
Atreides and not long after the official
introduction of Zendaya's character
chani Dune began a sprawling tale of
putting households political maneuvering
religious Intrigue and resource mining
on the desert planet of Iraqis told
through an impressive ensemble cast
of course not all the central players in
Dune survived until the end but those
who did are expected to reprise their
roles in the sequel also returning our
director Denise vanov and composer Han
Zimmer the latter of whom joked in a
tweet thank goodness I have some music
left as for vinov the director clarified
that he considers Dune part 2 the same
movie as dune rather than a traditional
sequel telling Hollywood Reporter it's
not a sequel where it's another episode
or another story with the same
characters it actually has direct
continuity to the first movie it's the
second part to the big huge movie that
I'm trying to do joining the cast for
Doom 2 are Florence Pugh who will play
Princess eroo land and Christopher
Walken as Emperor shaddam IV Elvis star
Austin Butler will portray the
villainous spade rauthaw and Leia sidhu
will join the cast as lady Margot unlike
the first film Dune part 2 will receive
an exclusive 45-day theatrical window as
opposed to the simultaneous theatrical
and streaming release that the first
film got this was a non-negotiable for
villanov who says that for him the
theatrical experience is at the very
hearts of the Cinematic language
another sequel to the 1984 Mega hit
Ghostbusters was on the table for
decades Dan Aykroyd had ambitious plans
but they never panned out instead fans
got a reboot with 2016's Ghostbusters
which features a whole new set of spirit
trapping scientists it's a classic FM's
middling box office returns and just
okay critical reviews killed any chances
for a sequel so Sony went back to the
original Ghostbusters storyline with
2021's Ghostbusters afterlife set in the
world of the original two Ghostbusters
films with cameos from original cast
members and appearances from characters
like Egon spangler's daughter and
grandchildren the film was a hit at the
relatively subdued covet era box office
prompting Sony to order a sequel as the
end sequence of Ghostbusters afterlife
suggests the film will take place in New
York City just like the 80s Ghostbusters
films and we know that Paul Rudd and
Carrie [ __ ] are coming back for part two
in April 2018 The Hollywood Reporter
announced that aardman animations will
be revisiting The Henson roosters of
chicken run in a brand new sequel while
the follow-up film was originally
intended for theaters Netflix announced
in 2020 that the streamer would actually
be the home for the chicken run sequel
the screenplay for chicken run dawn of
the Nuggets is being crafted by Carrie
Kirkpatrick and John O'Farrell both of
whom worked on the original chicken run
along with Rachel tannard as for the
director the film is in the fine
stop-motion hands of Sam fell filmmaker
behind ParaNorman the story will once
again feature Rocky and ginger now
played by Zachary Levi and dandy Way
Newton living happily in a human-free
island Sanctuary with their young chick
Molly but when chickens come under
threat again Rocky and ginger decide to
leave their peaceful home to once again
fight for all chicken kind
when the action thriller extraction hit
Netflix in 2020 it was announced as the
most watched original film in Netflix's
history making a sequel practically
inevitable sure enough less than two
weeks after extraction premiered on the
streamer a deadline reported that a
sequel was already in the works Chris
Hemsworth set to return the sequel will
once again center around mercenary Tyler
rake through the first teaser confirmed
survived the original film despite all
evidence to the contrary that said
writer Joe Russo has indicated that he's
just as interested in exploring reik's
backstory as he isn't following him
after the events of extraction so the
plot really could go in any direction
although we don't yet have a release
date for extraction 2 we know it will be
coming out in 2023. Russo also has big
plans for the extraction franchise
beyond the sequel saying that his ccxp
panel we are working at building out a
universe of films that could potentially
explore some of the other characters
from the first movie and some new
characters and see more historical
interaction between the characters
on his 35th birthday in 1988 Julius
Benedict was informed that he was
separated at Birth from his twin brother
Vincent after they were both conceived
in a lab as part of a genetic experiment
twins followed the unlikely Duo as they
reconnected and uncovered the
long-buried secrets about their past now
33 years later the Benedict Clan is
growing yet again in triplets the sequel
will bring back Schwarzenegger and
DeVito as Julius and Vincent and they'll
be joined by Tracy Morgan as a yet
unnamed third brother the premise as
conveyed by original film director Ivan
Reitman who was slated to direct the
sequel until his death in 2022 will
start out similarly to the first film
with each of the brothers being
surprised to learn of another sibling's
existence Reitman said of the film's
plot to deadline they don't know each
other and very early in the movie they
meet it's how they achieve a bond
together after all these years it's
really a film about family and no matter
how different we all are we have to
learn to get along following reitman's
passing the status of the film felt
uncertain but Schwarzenegger seemed
confident that triplets would eventually
move forward in other words he's got a
clear message to the legions of twins
fans the world over
I'll be back
[Music]